we also send volunteers to ukraine as
the president of the newly formed group
kalona stands with ukraine speaks to a
ukrainian city mayor the reality of war
hits hard you want to say something
a rate warning i have to escape to
bomb shelter we wait for alexander
tretchak to make his way down to the
bomb shelter where he continues the zoom
call the two men discussing the idea of
kalona and the city of rivne becoming
sister cities it's kind of taking them
under our umbrella rivne is located in
northwestern ukraine close to the border
with belarus on tuesday a television
tower was bombed outside of the city 21
ukrainian troops died any minute putin
can break our borders and can send his
troops on our region after seeing all
the support from kelowna residents on
social media the mayor of rivne reached
out for more help that got the president
of kelowna stands with ukraine taking
that request for help one step further
making an official request here at city
of kelowna for evening to become our
sister city it's much better to focus
and be in the right connection because
our idea is not just sending like some
truckloads of humanitarian aid whether
it's used or not maybe half of that will
be thrown away but work on the specific
uh things that they need specific
connection that's that's what we try to
do the request will be before city
council this coming monday city
councilor mohini singh says establishing
a sister city relationship with her
evening is absolutely worth exploring
we've been very generous to communities
in the past i can see if there's need
there i can see us fundraising to help
communities help schools help colleges
help hospitals so on and so forth to
help that community get back on its feet
in the meantime as russia continues its
brutal and unprovoked attack on ukraine
the mayor of our potentially future
sister city is making an impassioned
plea for help to send any humanitarian
aid that we can long-term food
boxes
with medicine with uh
with
individual first aid kits for our
soldiers i would be very grateful for
you i would be very appreciated for you
he also asked global news to keep
reporting on the atrocities in ukraine
and encouraging all residents to fly
ukrainian flags as a symbol of
solidarity claudia van number global
news kalona